freitagsgebet in der mannheimer moschee
der imam ruft die gläubigen zu einem
einwandfreien lebenswandel auf die
religiösen gesetze des islams scharia
regeln alle bereiche auch das
wirtschafts und finanz leben gutes solo
versorgt nie die predigt er zieht hier
raus moralische kraft auch für seinen
job als banker banking solltet lässt
sich den menschen helfen und das kann
dadurch geschehen dass man ethische
werte auch ein einheit wie
nachhaltigkeit fairness im umgang mit
den kunden mit den kreditnehmern und
also letztlich werte die hinter den
jeder mensch den kann unabhängig davon
welche religion oder weltanschauung er
angehört in mannheim will er die erste
deutsche islam bank an den start bringen
verboten sind die muslimin zum beispiel
geschäfte mit unternehmen die mit
alkohol und schweinefleisch handeln und
er als banker dafür der zinsen erheben
noch spekulieren
das zinsverbot mutet in deutschland fast
zu exotisch an wie das logo seiner
türkischen mutter bank
und so funktioniert die zinslose
finanzierung aufsucht mit dem wunsch ein
auto oder ein kühlschrank oder was auch
immer zu finanzieren und alles andere
die bedingungen liegen vor
dann kaufen wir das von ihm gewünschte
gut aufschlagen dann unseren gewinn
darauf und verkaufen es weiter anderen
kunden der das seinen ratenzahlung bei
uns abbezahlt manche nennen das einen
umgehungsgeschäfte gewinnaufschlag bei
der islam bank oder zinsen bei der
konventionellen das mache doch kein
großer unterschied
doch die berater stellen klar dass die
islam bank eben auch das risiko ihrer
kunden betrage bei unternehmen meist mit
einer beteiligung einsteigen
das kommt an also als muslime ist es
sehr wichtig für uns ich denke nicht nur
als muslime sondern auch als
alternatives finanzsystem möglichkeiten
für alle die in deutschland leben doch
dafür muss die bank erst richtig
loslegen dürfen
die kundengelder können noch nicht in
deutschland angelegt werden sondern
werden in der türkei islam konform
verwaltet soldo hat jetzt den antrag auf
eine vollbanklizenz gestellt und will
ein bundesweites filialnetz aufziehen
er hofft auf glänzende geschäfte nicht
nur mit den rund vier millionen muslimen
die in deutschland leben
im institut für islamische studien in
mannheim schreibt er an seiner
doktorarbeit
pseudo will herausfinden wie islamische
staaten erfolgreich wirtschaften können
das in der finanzkrise nicht eine
einzige islamische bank in die insolvenz
gegangen ist findet er schon
nachdenkenswert aus unserer sicht sind
die wichtigsten faktoren die dazu
geführt haben
das transparenzgebot spekulationsverbot
und auch der mechanismus das eben jedem
zahlungsstrom ein reales gut oder
dienstleistung unterlegt sein muss und
das führt dazu dass auf der
gesamtwirtschaftlichen ebene der
kreditsektor im einklang mit dem real
sektor wachsen muss es zu keinen
kreditblasen und krisen auf
gesamtwirtschaftlicher ebene kommen kann
eine botschaft auch für die frankfurter
city von hier aus will solo den
deutschen markt erobern
die wirtschaftsförderung unterstützt
seine pläne und auch die genehmigung der
bankenaufsicht gilt als so gut wie
sicher
als nächsten produkt kann es sehr
erfolgreich entwickeln und also 5
prozent marktanteil
mittel bis langfristig könnte mir das
sehr gut vorstellen den großen banken in
frankfurt wird auch als solo keine
konkurrenz machen können
als pionier das islamic banking in
deutschland bekannt zu machen
darauf dafür hoffen